nous sommes le 5 avril 2011 les parents
et l'oncle de loïc lamboeuf sont
effondrés et en colère quelques jours
plus tôt loïc est mort noyé dans une
cuve alors qu'il était en stage à
l'entreprise véolia de montceau les
mines pour eux loïc a été victime d'un
manquement grave aux règles de sécurité
après leurs condoléances le drh de la
religion vers les religions nous a
carrément dit que c'était de la faute de
notre fils parce qu'on lui avait
signifié de ne pas dépasser des
certaines limites
une certaine limite en limites
virtuelles bien entendu moi je suis
désolé en sécurité la limite virtuelle
elle n'existe pas c'est où il y as
danger et on balise où il n'y a pas
danger et à ce moment là il n'y a pas de
limite on peut pas dire une limite
virtuels le 29 mars vers 8 heures on
avait demandé à loïc de nettoyer seuls
les grilles qui surplombe les cultes de
dégazage
s'inquiétant de ne plus voir le
stagiaire des salariés alerte les
secours qui arrivent à 9h30 le laps de
temps qui s'est écoulé entre la
constatation de sa disparition et et les
recherches effectuées me laisse à penser
qu'il a pas été on va dire laisser seuls
quelques instants le 5 avril 2011 tout
le lycée dolto de montceau rendait
hommage à loïc
depuis la justice à travailler veolia va
donc se retrouver devant le tribunal de
chalon en tant que personne morale pour
répondre d'une série de manquements à la
sécurité sont aussi prévenu le directeur
du site de montceau et le directeur
régional de veolia